the short answer is no as authorities
have moved to clamp down on excessive
leverage in the property sector we've
seen time and time again that they've
proved they are willing to allow some of
china's kind of bigger
developers to fail and that they're
willing to do that at the expense of
many global investors
essentially concerns over the scope of
developers hidden debt and concerns that
even strong developers now may be under
pressure when it comes to refinancing or
access funding for some of their debts
is provoked a repricing of risk even
across some of china's bigger uh and
once considered safer developers what
that means is contagion risks across the
industry could rise and this could
spread well beyond just the property
industry into the financial industry and
into the broader economy
the big new risk this year is seeing
that some of china's biggest and
strongest developers are now being hit
with many concerns over potential hidden
debt and over concerns that their access
to funding might be tightened now that's
crucial because this year chinese
property developers need to repay or
refinance about 99 billion dollars worth
of bonds
[Music]
nearly half of those are offshore bonds
and while many of the weaker developers
have been unable to pay those debts
triggering a wave of defaults stronger
firms have been assumed
to be able to access the market and
access funding
now we're seeing fresh concerns that may
no longer be the case